name review welcome everyone to meme
review yeah I'm a gamer g-o Lavoie I'm
sure everyone's already heard and I know
it devastated me it shook me to my core
Pro Jared cheated on his wife
what the Frick dude I used to love it
lean tender reviews what the man that
looks exactly like the guy from lost
cheated on his wife what unbelievable
so the wife fair apparently spared no
hidden hell back saying hey I recently
learned that my husband has been
freaking behind my back for months I
have proof I have evidence and he's
gonna die even going after the person he
cheated with Jesus Christ okay and
everything just happened at once then
pictures of you know I don't want to get
into the detail that's for pew news I
think what's important here is the memes
okay I don't really care about anything
else right now
I just want to go haha thank God I'm not
the one in the controversy today ha look
at that guy he messed up you know you
messed up when DSP out of old people
drives you on Twitter
yes I cheated and I'm okay with that
that's why my final rating for this is a
broken marriage out of 10 oh you'll
excuse me I need to delete some pictures
of myself playing naked you wanna see
him No Delita
delete the pro Jarrod please that's why
I rate this a broken marriage on man
goddammit Pro Jarrod he was leaving his
hint all along
why did we not listen to him we shared a
blessing he's most viewed video how to
make slender not scary tip number one
cheat on your wife what even pro
jarrett's own mods join in in the
slaughtering that has been pro charrid
the internet his wife pro Jarrod Pro
Jarrod muds gamer headset on knuckles
crack
wife cheated on oh it's gamer time I
think what's funny by this is how
jontron you know the guy that was kicked
out of their collective group for saying
things I don't know exactly what he said
but bad things he said bad things we
demand that you talk about your old
friends PP jontron I guess he got the
last laugh Pro Jared losing hundreds
hundred thousand subscribers in just
that one day just after hitting a
million subs when you unsubscribe from
Pro Jared after watching him for more
than seven freaking years I used to
watch his videos back in the day Mike
maybe for your 3 years ago or something
they're not bad videos I don't really
care I just want the me look he looks
just like him hahaha I like the fact
that whatever go to any picture on his
Instagram it's all clowns
it's just clowns y'all got clown Don you
unlocked a clown outfit while we now
it's worth mentioning we haven't fully
heard Jared side of the story
and a lot of things are bothering me
about this whole thing there's a lot of
puzzle pieces that don't really make
sense to me
I don't think both parties are are
completely blameless here but that's for
Papa Gloria to decide in her video
that's probably coming up tomorrow
moving on Pro Jared gets a broken
marriage out of 10 thanks me we have a
lot of memes today's listen therapist
not Nicolas Cage sonic doesn't exist he
can't hurt you Nicolas Cage Jesus Christ
that is absolutely beautiful
why was Nic Cage not ah so now people
are doing all you've probably seen these
already people doing this CGI Photoshop
for the new Sonic since they said
they're gonna fix them and oh boy oh boy
that looks fantastic it still looks
better than the original still better
than the original was it really that
hard my god you know you messed up when
Garfield looks better i sonic and then
the original you know you messed up when
they
dog from paint looks better than the
original Sonic and you know you're
messed up when this looks like a way
more interesting movie
it bothers me why couldn't they just
have embraced the mean goddammit it
pissed me off
fair no Sonic why we now they sick see
here that's pretty good okay I've seen
enough stop it stop stop it now please I
don't want to see this no one asks for
this
stop it now thank you stop it ends here
Hey look who's Belle Delphine Sonic I
really like the one I did doctor feel
something I really op it how it turned
out but I'm even happier about the fact
that the man the myth the legend himself
liked it on Twitter thank you doctor
feels very cool Sonic means gets a
broken marriage out of time next me my
therapist you need to you need to stop
fixating on skull cow it's not the real
and it can't hurt you
skull care skull of can Scott Scott
Scott Scott Scott Scott
my therapist while away our nickel isn't
real he can't hurt you Wally trionic oh
Jesus mrs. memes now thinks that should
never exist and that exists this
abominations it's not funny I feel
uncomfortable therapist Broadview
characters can hurt you
they don't Excel my god ah therapist
insolent lephant what isn't real it
can't hurt you in cell elephant angry
wild elephant destroyed cars and houses
in China after failing to find a
girlfriend to me in cell elephant now
that's the word I never thought I'd say
there appears girlfriend isn't real he
can't hurt you thank God
Garfield gets real no oh god what is
this the yugioh hair monster isn't real
it can't hurt you please I have enough
nightmares already is it my own existent
enough for me to dread you have to dread
the existence of all these other
abominations
spun Jesus is not real he can't your bum
Jesus please stop please stop
I can't do it anymore shallow man there
isn't really can't hurt
so um I like a poke about by article
Apple God stopped destroying the good
word of Bionicles my article Apple isn't
really can't hurt you an email after
initiate ps1 Hagrid isn't real
now that's the true horror game goddamn
bath dog isn't real it can't hurt you
BAFTA bath dog fish skin isn't real it
can't hurt you
face cat space good irate please mean a
broken marriage I'll attend next me now
this next mean I'm not gonna lie it does
bother me quite a bit okay because it's
racism Scandinavian people don't talk
like this okay insecurity I always be a
part of you anxiety I wonder what could
go wrong drowning Scandinavian yes I
feel of much fine it's funny because
it's sir yep help me I fell off my ship
Marseille always makes fun of me for the
way we pronounce the I I am Sweden like
racism okay any other race oh oh that's
not but that's no mean and degrading
also Scandinavians haha
Scandinavian clown junk yeah that's true
Scandinavian coking attic I can't tell
if this is funny just for me but it is
funny because it's 100% accurate swedish
dog be attic no that one's not real
norwegian flip-flops
yep see what has happened to me mister
sink so frickin love scandinavian
burglar this is a burglary
I think it would maybe more this is a
burglary Scandinavian circumcision is
sips Oh God I had enough standing hip
here toilet yes can you flush flush
Scandinavian dwarf
sure not me
however I am NOT shirt I have known
Scandinavian like wing McQueen I am yes
yeah this is not how we talk this is all
right thing
Scandinavian cam yeah well there you go
Scandinavian horse Nick yeah yeah I rate
this mean a broken marriage out of that
that's it for this week's main review
what memes do you want me to destroy
next time let me know in the comments
down below and I'll see you guys
tomorrow with another average below
average slightly video enjoy then
subscribe for more of those by the way I
don't know it would be great if more
people subscribed I think that's what
this channel needs at this point so
thank you so much for hitting that
subscribe button thank you thank you so
much that's really cool of you honestly
means so it means the world to me what
you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]